[Music]
you
is integrate both Geographic data
so that you can see where the most
prevalent cases are flu are happening
within this particular region as well as
additional data sets from outside of
this health system these are public
weather data sets that are available on
top of Google cloud platform for anybody
to integrate into their clinical or
operational types of analysis and so
here we're integrating NOAA weather data
to look at snowfall and precipitation
and understand how those track to the
different case rates that we see a flu
underneath our cloud CDW is Google
bigquery and Google bigquery is a
incredibly powerful managed database for
analytics
it's a columnar database so it works
very very fast very very efficiently at
analyzing great big chunks of data and
analyzing time series types of data that
we often see within the healthcare space
it's fully managed which means that you
don't need to worry about the
infrastructure for it you just go
straight to cloud Google calm / bigquery
and it's there ready for you to use and
it's safer because we automatically
encrypt all of the data that's in
bigquery and the way that we set up
projects on bigquery as part of cloud
CDW enables you to meet your HIPAA
compliance needs as well so we have
deployment manager templates that in a
setup
bigquery projects and Google cloud
projects in a way that helps you to
satisfy your HIPAA requirements
in addition because we have these public
and commercial datasets available you
can integrate these into the analysis
you're doing and I'll show you some
examples of those different datasets as
well but most powerfully its scalable so
you can throw petabytes of data at this
and it doesn't blink behind the scenes
it scales up horizontally so it's
looking ahead at the analysis you're
trying to do and just brings additional
machines additional compute power to
bear as it sees that you need it and
interestingly for a columnar database
everything is queryable through sequel
which means that we have a host of
different tools that you can use on top
of bigquery directly for doing your
business intelligence and your
visualization Google has its own Google
Data studio but in addition all of these
different ones up here are shown as well
and these all have direct integrations
into bigquery the dashboard
we're in the horror movie today can you
tell
I should just thank you yeah the
dashboard that used oh we're not up
there though
well the dashboard that you saw before
was created with a looker but we've also
created dashboards using tableau and
using my crisp strategy and others as
well thank you if you don't mind staying
here and just wobbling it occasionally
Thank You chief wobbler
so as you've probably heard this week
we've been delighted to announce that
our healthcare API has moved to beta and
what that means is now you can ingest
healthcare data into Google cloud
platform in its native formats in fire
not not too many people yet are using
fire ingesting it directly in fire form
into big into Google cloud platform but
we're starting to see that as customers
are upgrading their EMR versions to the
latest versions that support fire
interfaces most of the data that we see
coming from EHRs today comes to us in
hl7 version 2 format and that's part of
the cloud healthcare API as well and in
addition we also support DICOM images so
any medical radiology types of image
that you have can also be ingested
natively in this format directly onto
Google cloud platform and then what I'm
showing on the right-hand side is just a
simple sequel statement that's joining
EHR and imaging data together and this
is the type of cross modality day for
analysis you can do once you've got all
your data together in bigquery so that
sounds lovely and easy we all know in
practice that every single data source
is different from the next and I always
like to say imaging data is nice and
large it's relatively simple EHR data
small and messy and
when we think about harmonizing data we
think about the bulk historical data
that you want to bring into a cloud CDW
as well as the incremental or streaming
sources that you're bringing in and
typically for your bulk data those are
in CSV formats or it's some kind of
direct connection through to an external
database but for incremental data as
well as those types of source it might
also be an hl7 version to messages or
fire messages or other types of
streaming data like that and what we
need to do in order to harmonize this
data is think about four key aspects
harmonizing the field mappings so
understanding the source schemas that
you're coming from multiple schemas what
your target schema is within your cloud
CDW and I'll talk a little bit about
that in a minute and then thinking about
how you map those schemas the fields
between them in order that when you say
patient over here and Pat ID over there
and Pt ID over there they all go to the
right patient ID that you've defined
within bigquery the next area is
terminology mappings because we all know
that particularly when you acquire a new
health spittle into your health system
or a new clinic into your health system
or maybe because you're trying to
integrate data from lots of different
sources that are Messier then different
sources use different terminologies let
me give you an example I've worked with
health systems where some of the
medication data has been in rxnorm
but other medication data has been in
FDB because one particular Hospital
relies on FDB as its medication
vocabulary and so understanding how you
convert between these different
terminologies is also something that you
need to do is you harmonize this data
the next area is around units alignments
if any of you have ever visited a NICU
you'll know that the weight of babies of
of knee
babies is often weighed in grams whereas
the weight of the adult patients in
other ice-t use within that same health
system is typically measured in kilos if
we're lucky
or pounds more commonly and so aligning
the units as well becomes really
important not just for things like mass
but also for things like labs as well
and then clinical entity extraction I
think we've all become very familiar
with physician burnout and understanding
how using how physicians like to either
dictate or type up their note and so
extracting out the richness of that data
into the structured data augmenting the
structured data with the wealth of
information that's often buried within
the clinical notes from the providers
becomes really important now today you
can do all of this in cloud CDW but you
have to do it manually and so the tools
that we're working on will help to
automate a lot of this and over time add
machine learning to it so that it can
start to suggest the mappings to you
over on the right hand side here are the
target schemas so just as we recognize
healthcare data in its native formats as
first-class citizens we also recognize
certain schemas that are typically used
for healthcare analysis as first-class
citizens as well and starting at the top
there is fire so if you're looking for a
way to start converting to fire
converting your data to fire this gives
you a path to that the second one listed
here is ohm op the ohm op common data
model which Greg klebanov is going to
talk a bit more about in a moment and
then underneath i2b2 and cfdisk
and frankly any other schema because we
all know that many health systems or for
certain analyses there are always
schemas that already exists that people
need to continue using at least for a
while so you don't need to change the
approach you're taking
in order to leverage cloud CDW so right
now fire an ohm op exist as target
schemas within cloud CDW as well as the
custom schemas they exist as well and
then we'll be adding si disk and i2b2
over time of course you set up your data
harmonization rules and then everything
changes your source changes maybe your
source schema changes epic releases a
new version Cerner releases a new
version your vocabularies change because
they're always being updated or your
target schema changes everything changes
along the way and so you need to be
watching for those changes and so around
this data harmonization and all these
transformations is the framework to
enable you to monitor and to manage
lifecycle changes within this and
included within that something that
we're starting to work on now is
understanding when data is exception but
also what limits of exception you will
allow through with warnings versus what
things will really alert you because you
need to do something about that and
we're leveraging the concepts of
statistical process control which is
very common within manufacturing
industry in order to help drive that
decision-making around when to alert
when to warn when to let pass through
and the lifecycle management becomes
critical because from a data provenance
perspective when you're looking to try
and track back the data then you also
need to understand where that data came
from and so understanding which version
of the data harmonization was in place
at that time and exactly what that
transformation was where the sources of
data were that came that becomes really
important
I mentioned the public data sets before
we now have over a hundred public data
sets available on bigquery that you can
just integrate into
any analysis join as tables into any
analysis that you're doing on bigquery
these are some of the healthcare and
life science ones available there's a
bunch of biomedical data sets that we're
bringing on as part of the NIH strides
initiative and then there's a fair bit
of Medicare and Medicaid data from CMS
but we're also always in the process of
adding more datasets and right now my
focus is trying to ensure that we add
more social determinants of health data
sets that will help with the analysis
that you're trying to do within your
populations
once you've harmonized all that data
what do you want to do with it maybe you
just want to create some kind of
dashboard some kinds of analytics that
will help you understand things like the
longitudinal patient record or maybe you
need to create analytics that are
portable so I think about defining
cohorts of patients in the same way that
I think about needing to enable
clinicians to do those definitions in
terms that they understand so not
looking at the detailed fields and
saying are I want to select on this
field and I need to join it with that
thing over there but rather enabling a
user interface that clinicians can say
look these are my inclusion criteria and
these are my exclusion criteria and be
able to leverage common definitions for
things like certain conditions
leveraging clinical quality metric
definitions and leveraging other common
definitions that are out there in our
industry and so you'll be able to create
your cohort definitions and underneath
these will be made portable so that you
can then apply those cohort definitions
to any data set that could be enabled
within fire so this becomes really
powerful for you because it helps to
protect your investment
when as well as cohort definitions you
can think of query definitions and
metric definitions in the same way so
we'll be couching behind the scenes
these definitions within fire and of
course will help you get to fire so that
that way if you bring on another data
set all you need to do is realign it to
fire and then apply that definition on
top of it and that could be a query that
could be a metric that could be a cohort
and over time will also enable you to
share these definitions with others as
well and so that too helps particularly
in the research world particularly as
you're looking at doing more
collaboration with others in your field
another reason why people want to bring
all of this data together and I've spent
quite a bit of time this week talking to
several people about this is in order to
use it for machine learning in order to
use it either to train a model or more
often right now to be able to infer data
to be able to predict data using
somebody else's model well we'll meet
you where you are we have a range of
different machine learning tools api's
and techniques that can help you and all
of these work directly on top of
bigquery and on top of our cloud CDW
over on your left are the ones that
require more engineering so things like
tensor flow or being able to leverage
spark ml crowd c ml e in the middle are
some of the predefined models that we
have available so for example our
natural language api our video
intelligence api and also our
translation api and then over on the
right bigquery
ml which so far is primarily for
classification and regression z' but
over time may expand as well in its
capabilities
so if you want to train machine learning
models bring it on bring it into cloud
CDW and then have all of these different
tools available for you to do that now
if you're trying to apply somebody
else's models on top of the data in
cloud CDW will help you do that too
so our framework will let you invoke
other machine learning api's as well to
make those predictions finally you've
done that and in some cases that's it
right you're using that data internally
in other cases particularly in some
research cases you want to de-identify
that data in order to make it available
to researchers and so the d
identification api is the first step on
the way to being able to share those
datasets more broadly with other
researchers we have other things in the
works there as well but this is what's
available right now and this the
identification works not just on
structured data that's relatively easy
but also on imaging data so if there is
pH I burned into the medical image
pixels which there often is and it also
works on unstructured clinical notes as
well and in addition on the structured
data if you already have some
de-identified data we can now present
back to you the risk of
re-identification of that data as well
so that you can understand where the
risk lies on a spectrum I talked a
little bit about this actually last year
when I said I think we'd run three data
thumbs at that point on GCP and had I
think another six coming up in the next
year well that proliferated they bred
like bunnies and we've actually
supported now eleven over the last year
these are a great way to get your team's
direct experience of using GCP with
healthcare data and they're held around
the world if anybody would like more
information come
pantheus at the end and but this is
essentially a little package that allows
organizers to host healthcare data funds
in an appropriate environment for that
and so if you want to host a data thumb
come up and see us just bring your data
set to us and we're happy to help get
that set up with you or if you are
interested in attending them or having
it having one of your team attend one
let us know as well typically what
happens is over the course of a weekend
everybody gets together and really
blacks out clinical data science on top
of bigquery and on top using data
science tools so with that I'd like to
hand over to Josh who's going to talk
about on the data ingestion process how
you take that data x12 data in this case
and convert it into fire and with Josh's
Allen as well thank you thank you Marian
is everybody excited to take a look at a
deep dive at the clinical data hiding in
x12 ANSI format woohoo yes all right
so as as some of you may know care cloud
is a electronic practice management and
electronic medical records system
platform entirely hosted in the cloud
and one of the reasons why we're here
with you guys today is we've been a
technology partner working with the GCP
team particularly on the healthcare API
for the better part of the last year so
going through the the various alpha
phases I mean one of the things that
we've been able to do that we want to
demonstrate for you today as Marianne
mentioned you know all of the great
power and insight that you can gain from
your data having it formatted in fire
and having it prepared for prediction
this is an example of how that can be
done and frankly how easy it looks once
you've taken the time to build that out
in your in your own systems so how many
people in here are familiar with x12 and
have dealt with that as a data format
show of hands okay not too many people
will well will dive into what what it's
useful but primarily this is the way
that electronic practice management
systems medical record systems big
pharmacy benefit management companies
transact between each other right this
is a forty-year-old interoperability
format we were both born in nineteen
seventy nine that's that's why I like
x12 but it's in use quite prevalent Lee
across all of the big payers right and
what that means is a lot of the data
data that we want to answer analyzed
longitudinally you know especially when
you think about the clinical perspective
is locked up in these really old
archival data formats so fire coming
around and now with fire v4 we're
standardizing on a normative model that
is going to allow us to essentially
continue with backward compatibility
have this normative format that we can
do analysis on so care cloud because of
the way that we service our existing
provider customers already has to has
invested a lot of technology and
know-how into translating very specific
detailed data you know in this case
bidirectionally right so we're talking
about fully interoperable bi-directional
semantic translation of data from the
different the various components of X 12
messages into the equivalent fire
resource that's a mouthful so we're
going to actually pop into a
demonstration to you know kind of show
how easy it is once it's been put into
practice Alan Alan Pulido here is our
technical lead who's team did all the
developments so he's up here making it
happen so this is this is our console
we're announcing here at the conference
the beta of this as part of the beta for
the healthcare API so this is going to
be available through the marketplace or
working with us we can offer this as a
managed service or a SAS offering but
we're gonna go through how simple the
configuration is to go from an X 12
archive into fire resources in the
Google healthcare API right so we're
going to start
we're gonna go through and configure a
tenant right and if you if you think
about the various different ways that
x12 can be managed inside an
organization you might have you know
dozens or hundreds of different x12
definitions for a single message type in
a large payer organization so in this
case you know we're going to say we have
options for the sources during the beta
GCSE is obviously our favorite but you
know if you're looking to to move into
the Google healthcare API from you know
somebody else those are available as
well if we if we pop over it's as simple
as you know basically configuring the
bucket that you want to pull the data
out of and targeting your fire server in
this case it's the Google healthcare API
right I'll do another quick survey
before we kick this next part off how
many of you have your own fire servers
or have a team of engineers back home
that are trying to build your own fire
solution okay even if you're not go back
home and tell everybody to stop doing
that right we've been you know I'll
testify for a second from just personal
experience we went through a lot of the
open source projects evaluated nearly
all of them went so far as to even look
at developing our own cloud hosted fire
server in-house really when you look at
the amount of raw engineering that it
takes to get that all the way through
you know take advantage of the work that
that Kurt is doing there that team is
really strong they're really committed
to maintaining the standard and you know
frankly the the service is really
performant as we've gotten through the
various phases of the Alpha it's really
at a place where it's it's enterprise
grade production strength you can really
pump a lot of data through it so now
we're gonna go ahead and trigger a sweep
of all of the in this case 837 claims so
this is well we talked about how many
people had ever seen in 837 so we're
gonna give you a sneak peek at what that
actually looks like so if you're a COBOL
programmer if you like mainframes this
is this is what we love but locked in
here is all of the valuable
procedures that were performed on the
patient the related diagnoses that were
that were used as the supporting
clinical rationale for why that that
procedure was performed all of the
patient detailed demographics right it's
um it's a very good dense data format
you know forty years ago when you really
needed to transact between mainframes
and frankly there's billions of dollars
of existing investment in keeping this
format operational and this is frankly
the backbone of the way that we process
medical claims in the US so if we go
back you know again thinking about the
power of the way GCP allows us to build
data pipelines and do these types of
transformations we can do this at batch
or in a streaming fashion right so as
these extra lessons are being generated
we can translate them on the fly now if
you flip roll this forward now as more
and more of our industry as Tran is
standardizing on fire as the primary
data format this type of semantic
translation allows us to take the fire
resource and translate it now back into
X 12 which is the format that that your
mainframes are typically going to be
processing so we can pop in and we we
call it a human readable x12 message and
that means that you know really you're
an analyst that specified specializes in
looking at these types of data but
breaking it out by the various loops and
segments you can see kind of the the
nested hierarchy the way this this data
gets generated right and again we're
talking about that full fidelity
capability of translating it on the wire
we have we have another legacy format if
you guys are familiar with this this is
a CMS 1500 but you know again you think
about the power of being able to have
this type of semantic mapping you can
just you know talk about processing
images we can generate the CMS 1500
claim form directly from well what would
have been an electronic claim submission
now the the real power and and where
this flows into the clinical data
analysis is being able to get into the
fire resource itself
so if you're thinking about modern
development languages modern programming
techniques you know most folks are not
going to be building those applications
and those capabilities against that
native x12 format but there is a
semantic mapping and there is a way of
representing it as a fire resource you
know in this case we can go down and
take a look at the we'll take a look at
the diagnosis or do you want to look at
the oh you got that okay their claim ID
right so again we're talking about
bringing this from a legacy or an
archival claim storage right Fire is
really good at being able to identify
resources across systems right and if
you're bringing something out of a
legacy system maintaining the identity
integrity from the system that generated
it and as you move it out to the fire
server being able to reference it
without having to copy it right and for
all of us here as you know true
believers in clinic and clinical data
analysis and healthcare IT in general
right this allows us as Marianne
mentioned as we're as we're publishing
datasets as we're evolving our ability
to make this data useful and available
we can leave that data in the resident
fire server right where the the entity
that's responsible for managing it is
and we can reference it through fire
right and so that that's that's really
our goal here is to mean that maintain
that identity integrity so the other
great part is now if you think about the
way EMRs and everybody are building the
supporting information clinically that
all gets represented in fire as a
procedure code and a diagnosis code
right and they're mapped here so that
you have the link diagnosis with all of
the procedures that were performed on
the patient now in our case I know I
know we mentioned a few a few other EMRs
but some Myanmar's out there are
generating their their clinical data in
a fire compatible format so you know as
these things evolve no this is really
where we can start to find out things
totally new right maybe there's a
propensity to not go to your follow-up
appointment after your last claim list
tonight right now if your
if you're putting these these data
together you can start to map out how
patients were treated against how the
financial information was actually
transacted between the patient and their
insurance company will give you a little
okay good there well back to the science
the joys of Av okay so the last bit you
know we have to have a ubiquitous market
extra slide or it doesn't seem like
anybody's doing anything so the idea is
that all of these pipelines are built in
GCP right we're talking about using the
the same you know powerful tools that
Mary Ann mentioned that's everything
that transacted there right going from
from GCP is or GCS is the the the source
data format moving through data flow you
can take the picture but you need the
Edison engine in the middle there to
actually do the semantic translation but
you know this really does work at scale
right we've tested this into the the
millions of messages generating we did
it we did an interesting conversion with
a data set that we might potentially
open source where we created 4.3 million
fire resource bundles out of the nppes
data set that's publicly available in
bigquery and it ran in about 15 minutes
so it's you know and that's in a single
data flow pipeline these are really
powerful tools that are really ready to
handle our scale of data you know in
this case now the all of the data that
we've ingested is is prepared and ready
in the in the fire API to be leveraged
by all of the other capabilities that
we've been that folks have been talking
about so you know all of this is key
right so what we're asking here coming
out of this if you have any if you have
any questions or you like to participate
in the beta if you can follow up with
any of us after the program we're
looking for folks that are potentially
looking to leverage gke on prem right
because all of this is being deployed in
kubernetes so you can either host it in
your your GCP project in your own
kubernetes container we can host into a
tease for you also but you know we think
that a lot of big healthcare
institutions are going to be keen on
trying out GK on pram and their own
VMware infrastructure we think that's
going to have some pretty significant
michaela mechanical advantages to to
have the data translation process as
close to the
the archival data as possible and then
you know as you think about moving out
to the cloud and moving from those
unfirm or collocations out to GCP you
know that data is already in GCP prep
for you in the healthcare api so with
that I'll hand it back to Marian you
very much so that's showing a real
example of how you can use GCP to
convert that claims data to fire ok can
you I don't know great and so actually I
think we want to go back to the slides
first sorry and so next up is Greg
klebanov CTO of Odysseus data services
we talked about OMA pers being one of
those standard schemas Greg's going to
talk more about that thank you Greg
hello everybody I'm Greg Club know from
the city of Odysseus dear services I
can't really see you but I know you're
there and you can see me so today I will
demo a tool that was developed
I've been maintained by the open science
open source community called RAC and
before I even dive into this demo I
would like to put the stool on and what
we do in the context of Odysseus or not
the science community so Odyssey it's
pronounced assadís it's built OS this I
stands for observational health data
Sciences informatics is a again an
international open source open science
open source community that is focused on
enabling standardized reproducible
scalable observational data analytics
across the world and we would like to
stress that Odyssey is is an open source
open science community meaning it's it's
public it's open its international and
anybody can join anybody can contribute
and anybody can use any of the tools in
standards and methods that are developed
by by this community it's worth
mentioning that Columbia University's
is a coordinating center across the
world as you can see RAC is a global
community it spoon responds multiple
countries multiple continents and today
you can see the statistics it's grown
quite quite nicely and work very closely
with our partners and collaborators in
the US in in Europe in Asia including
South Korea and China so the mission of
RAC is really improve public health by
enabling better health care decisions
based on evidence produced from Revolt
datasets and so one of the so RS again
as an open science open source community
that enabled key open standards
including a standard is called OMAP CDM
common data model this was CDM stands
for and the latest version version 6 you
can see it on the screen is quite mature
quite nicely developed so in addition to
common data model Odyssey else in able
to strand a set of standardized medical
vocabulary instead of standardized tools
and one of those tools is Atlas and I'll
show it to you today but before I dive
into Atlas I I just like to maybe talk a
little bit about the data journey of how
this data gets into data analytics
platforms like Cutlass so data sets what
kind of data sets of working with
working with clinical data sets or
called real world data that comes from
different types of organizations that
come from but they could be medical
insurance claims or electronic medical
records they could be a lab result
survey data clinical trial data chart
reviews and so on so any types of data
that you know scanning from a clinical
utilization of drugs and treatments we
essentially need to process and convert
into a standardized format called
obsidium so what's nice about all mimes
Omar CDI mode creates a single
standardized way of saving data so that
the data scientists the researchers only
have to design their query once and then
I can guarantee that this query is going
to run on in
Oh mops EDM database across the world
and I'm really excited to say that we
added so Atlas in any other tools
analysis these supporters I believe
close to nine different data sets the
absolute databases and I'm really
excited to to say that we also now
provide support for GCP platform
including a big data bigquery I'm sorry
bigquery database so what you see on
this screen is essentially is a is a
simplified architecture of Cobo process
data to convert entombed obsidium and
we've successfully converted data sets
actually pretty large data sets
utilizing data proc and Apache spark so
it's also worth mentioning that the day
says that we working most are very very
large in size so there can be very very
lush day again
medical claims data tend to grow on data
aggregators such as IBM Truman Marcus
care and databases can tend to be over
200 million patients in size for a
single database so typically mean tens
of billions of records that need to be
processed and converted from obsidium
I'm also very excited to say that
Odyssey Atlas which is Odyssey Atlas
that is probably one of the most common
in popular tools in a DC community also
now supports bigquery database
underneath and I'll give you a little
demo of that tool in second so Atlas is
a tool that was produced and is produced
in developed by a DC community so what
my company I'd issues daily services
were one of the most active contributors
in developing this tool and Atlas is a
tool that was designed to enable
research data science with an ability to
design complex analysis studies and then
execute those studies on on the top of
obsidian database
I need some magic here
great so bear with me one second so what
do you see right now on the screen is
the latest release of IDC Atlas - and
the tool is actually you know quite
mature at this point quite sophisticated
it offers multiple quiet nice features
including a full database level
characteristics which you will find it's
called Achilles
so I keyless is a full level database
level characterization of your data set
so you can imagine that before a
scientist even begins to to design their
study and research they would like to
know what's available in a database and
this information should be coming from
from Achilles Achilles allows you as a
researcher to see data stratified into
different types of dimensions that are
available in Omar CDM including it will
give you dashboard information
demographics information visit
information conditions information
procedures drag exposures measurements
and so on so it's for any research it's
very very easy to to come to Achilles
and just look up this specific database
contains information about a condition /
disease or a drug of their interest
before they even run a complex analytics
inquiry so another secret sauce in
obsidium is is a set of standardized
medical vocabulary so Sumerian
previously said drugs can be coded in
many different ways and the different
rxnorm exist and LCD vocabulary series
so one of the most fundamental standards
and decisions that Odyssey made is that
they decided to standardize so what our
team was actually doing they bring
together multiple medical vocabulary and
they sterilized on a single
representation of a drug on a single
representation of a condition so that
when data's been converted from raw data
in Soma
CDM date has been converted into
standardized representation of that
condition or a drug so here you know in
a plus you'll be able as a researcher to
search and browse medical vocabulary so
cohort any any any mature analytic
analytic analytical tool offers to the
cohort builder cohort design of some
sort and so Atlas is probably one of the
most sophisticated tools that been
developed in the industry so it allows
you as a researcher to design a very
sophisticated cohort information not
only you can design a cohort and I got
some examples there I'm gonna show you
in a second but you can also as you
design your cohorts you obviously take
advantage of standardized medical
vocabulary and then you can execute some
basic statistics immediately by
utilizing this cohort so for example
I've generated some counts I designed a
cohort that is meaningful to me so it's
ibuprofen being taken by a male over
forty years old
and I ran it against the CMS data set so
sympathy is a synthetic dataset
representation of CMS data claims data
and I can immediately see that my cohort
resulted in hundred and seventy thousand
seventy seven thousand patients that
would fit the cohort and immediately see
how my filters my criteria a limited
cohort selection at the end so cohort
are the building blocks in any data
analytics tool and again as you can see
this is run against the query database
so another gets more complicated of
course as as scientists they continue
the research they would like to know not
only how many patients do exist in a
specific dataset but I would like to get
a full characterization of that cohort
characterization meaning take this
cohort and stratified by different
dimensions by different that existed in
or obsidium dataset so for example in
this case specific case actually took
two whole cohort one aspirin users and
often users and I put them against right
so as you can see I can now characterize
my cohort by different criterias that
evil as a researcher to select then as
one of the latest features that was
there at an atlas is a treatment pathway
so especially treatment password is a
very important when for example oncology
patients going through treatment and
it's very often when oncology patients
going through treatment they go through
a multiple specific predefined treatment
pathway so in this specific case
actually it's not talking about oncology
it's talking about diabetes - but you
can see a pathway of treatment of
different patients of how to go from the
drug one into drug - and to directory
throughout their journey incident rates
basically instant rates provide exactly
what it means is the incident of certain
outcomes in the in the in the set of
cohort patients so in this specific case
it's an incident of intervention or what
that means but I'm sorry you can see it
here right so you can also see a more
complicated analysis estimation and
prediction analysis so estimation is
again is is a relative risk of something
happening based on your dataset in a
more complicated case just recently
added as a patient level prediction
analysis so patient little prediction
basically is is the probability of
something happening for a very specific
type of a patient probability of
developing certain condition in in the
future so patient level prediction is
just an example of again a personalized
treatment that it's possible today to to
develop for four different patients so I
know I have a very limited time analysis
as you can see is a pretty extensive -
it
I'm really excited to say that now to
supports bigquery as a as a database and
in the last words I would like to say
that again whatever you saw today Atlas
is not a source to so anybody can come
anybody can join the community
contribute we use it and I thank you for
attention
great thank you very much Greg so to
wrap up maybe there we go sort of my
closing message for you really it's
start bringing your health care and life
science data on to Google cloud start
thinking about the analytics that you
want to do start thinking about the
harmonizations that you need to do and
where you want that data do you want it
in fire persisted on GCP as care cloud
has been talked about do you want to
bring it into a specific target schema
to enable collaboration with others as
greg has talked about most importantly
you can get started now but plan ahead
for scale and think about how some of
the tools that we're building might help
you do that kind of data alignment
[Music]